true fashion does not always equal
comfort yep that's kim kardashian doing
her best to walk in a cat suit that's
covered head to toe in balenciaga
caution tape at their show for paris
fashion week on sunday it's a great look
this marked kim's second public
appearance since being declared legally
single her first appearance was last
thursday the mama 4 attended the revolve
social club vip opening in los angeles
where she rocked a biker chic black
leather balenciaga ensemble complete
with a black padded jacket matching
leggings and gloves black pointy heels
and a small black bag
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
on march 2nd the courts granted the
reality star's petition to be declared
legally single amid her divorce
proceedings with kanye west but this
does not mean her divorce is final in a
nutshell kim's marital status will now
be single while she continues to work
out a divorce settlement with the 44
year old rapper
god send me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
just a few hours after the judge's
ruling kanye released a disturbing music
video for his track easy
which shows yay kidnapping a claymation
figure eerily resembling kim's boyfriend
pete davidson then burying him in the
ground the cameras watch the kids i stop
taking the credit knocking studio dad i
bought the house next door
this
[Music]
the video ends with a reference to skeet
yay's go-to nickname for the comedian
a title card reads quote everyone lived
happily ever after
then quote except you know who with the
name skeet crossed out and finally jk
he's fine just do something for my heart
now source tells e.t kim is upset
because pete has been nothing but kind
and continues to be brought into kanye's
drama and doesn't deserve it i'm just
rolling with it the source adds quote
the couple is very happy and hopefully
over time kanye will come to terms that
kim being happy is all that matters
[Music]